the valor and competitive system is
supposed to be the steady tried and true
groundwork of the game but ever since
the game's launch has been an absolute
nightmare leaving riot games with their
hands full we all know things need to
change but what exactly are the problems
with ranked and is it really something
we should be complaining about
let's talk about it
[Music]
before we get into the video i'm going
to remind you to head over to the score
esports shorts channel same content you
love here just little okay sympathy for
you jet means you all deserve your nerf
it's no secret that ballarat has had
issues with ranked going all the way
back to the closed beta riot has been
pretty consistent addressing ranked
issues within its patches but ranked as
an absolute nightmare still just this
august riot publicly admitted that rank
distribution is not where they would
like to see it they said that the
majority of the game's 14 million
players are bunched up within silver and
low gold basically ranks and valerian
are bottlenecked and lopsided and riot
would like to see a more normal even
distribution and they're apparently
working on that the question is
why is it lopsided you can see how a
majority and in riot's opinion an
incorrect amount are in lower ranks why
is this happening are people hearts
stuck is it the system does riot have it
out for you
spoiler they don't well clearly a riot
is telling us that a vast majority of
players are stuck in silver and gold and
there's something wrong with the
distribution of ranks either people are
stomping and absolutely crushing their
games or not climbing up fast enough and
us bottom fraggers aren't losing enough
rr gears of that
simply put the ranked system isn't
working the stars should be rising and
those who are struggling should be
falling so if you're confused and
frustrated with your ranked experience
that is completely understandable well
fear not for i've researched every
single patch note since beta and i have
very loud opinions as to why rank
distribution is wonky and why ranked
simply put
sucks and no i'm not gonna be talking
about how we can't pick maps or toxic
teammates or whatever this is you know
you sound like you kind of do uh taxes
i sound like i do taxes yeah
what i'm talking about are game specific
issues that you cannot control you'll
have the ability to shut your mouth and
be nice for once but y'all don't have
the ability to control one rank
disparity and two smurfs are these
problems unique to valor absolutely not
you can take a look at riot's better
game league of legends
league has a myriad of problems within
it including a huge problem with
smurfing that being said i do think
these problems are uniquely severe and
valorant the nature of the agents and
valerian make it specifically easy to
pub stomp games with reyna's kit may as
well have been designed to smurf with in
addition to the issues with the agents
there's only one playing field when it
comes to ranked games there's no third
party platforms like faceit and cs go
here so that means the best players
don't have a hyper competitive
alternative to ranked to go to so it's
possible that some of those players
decide to stop try-harding and start
smurfing with their friends for an
easier time so when you have a bunch of
jets and rayness insta-locking duelists
and you have way too many people in the
silver purgatory that can lead to some
nasty ranked experiences now with that
in mind let's get to the first big point
that i think needs to be addressed maybe
the reason we have so many silvers is
because they're not playing with silvers
sounds odd right well that's the ranked
experience if you're silver 2 you
probably expect a bronze three to gold
one to be in your lobby at your most
generous understanding self which i'm
sure all of you are but it becomes kind
of shocking when a plat or even a gold
three comes in and carries you or the
enemy team in-game shots become about
one player and their much higher skill
level rather than their util or their
play style or whatever and just two
completely different stories when you
say hey
maybe you shouldn't go b because kj has
her set up there versus hey maybe we
shouldn't go b because kj claps us every
time that strategy is specifically only
for 100 thieves when they see cnn with
the zop and you could tell we were just
going away from him we're like all right
let's find cena and go everywhere
that's the straw basically you're either
constantly getting clapped or getting
carried there's no chance for you to
show your improved skills you're just a
little ping pong ball also this leads to
people who are in silver getting better
but they're not moving up so they're
playing at like a gold or even a plot
level but they're still stuck in silver
this leads us into somewhat related to
our second issue
smurfs people smurf for lots of
different reasons they want to play with
their lower level friends they want to
try out new util or new agents without
losing rr or they want to completely
destroy people to quote someone in a
recent pc gamer article in all honesty
it was fun as hell smoking people who
were new to the game
then there's also the issue of the
vicious cycle of smurfing if you're
constantly playing against smurfs you're
gonna get a little frustrated eventually
for a little relief you'll create a
smurf and then someone else is going to
create a smurf and the cycle repeats and
repeats and repeats in valorem smurfing
isn't so much a remedy for deadly long
queue times like it was when the game
first dropped as it is just for
having a fun time playing games in lower
elos to me those are the two major
issues in ranked and the good news is
riot is aware of them but the question
still remains
what can they do about it now despite
addressing that ranked is not in the
optimal spot they want it to be right
also doesn't want to give into any sort
of confirmation bias meaning they don't
want you to think it's their fault that
you're hard stuck silver aria dev said
in a lengthy reddit post that neither
the game nor any developer is quote not
here to make a system to give you a free
rank you don't deserve and that they
can't solve problems that don't exist
and they're not wrong i went through
every single patch note and competitive
has been addressed in not all but most
of them specifically in the 3.0 patch
riot said they wanted to make sure that
you were having fun in your ranked games
they said their primary goals were this
we want winning games to matter most at
all skill levels we want to improve
individual performance evaluation
because we believe it helps identify
more fair and balanced matches we want
you to see your rank as an accurate
representation of your current skill
level we want you to have fewer
motivations for playing on different
accounts and to get your proper rank
faster and as for smurfing and valorent
riot has addressed them before in
october 2020 they were aware of the
problem of smurfs and had deployed
strategies to combat them according to
senior producer ian feldick in october
quote right now we have a behind the
scenes system for unrated as well as one
that applies to iron through diamond
ranked players the latter tracks an
individual's performance and notices
when a player makes a highly
disproportionate impact in the game we
then quickly boost them to harder
matches and higher ranks than
competitive we stop leveraging the
system for immortal players because
there isn't a ton of room to smurf or
play down are actually already near the
top ranks this is all really great but
as of may 2021 riot said they were still
deep into an investigation about how to
deal with smurfs and actually according
to riot's data smarts are only a small
percentage of the population pros and
experts like our lord and savior shroud
think that smurfing is actually not that
big of a deal we just need to get good
smurfs can be a problem sure but i also
think the smurf excuse is over overused
they could truly be the rank that you
are at they are just feeling it for some
reason their mouse is just responding to
their hand very well
that could happen
smurfing is an issue sure but it's not
as big of an issue that everyone makes
it out to seem it's just not so at the
end of the day
why does this all matter well valerian
is a game that over 14 million people
enjoy with a variety of different
experiences for some people it is their
first fps and for some people this is
the game that they spend hundreds of
dollars and hours on yeah it's a
free-to-play game whatever but you
expect a certain kind of experience from
it clearly riot is aware that there are
issues with their game but honestly
shouldn't we expect that a popular
rather young gain that is growing every
single day is bound to have issues
furthermore wright has to make sure that
every single change they make is fair
and bountiful for everyone and if we're
being really honest guys riot is one of
the few developers that actually listen
to their community i know i'm not the
only one who feels this way guys i am
one of you i often find myself
frustrated and ranked whether it's my
friends or less often by myself
and i want it to be fun and good too all
good things take time and hopefully our
patients will be rewarded soon but if it
takes too much time
we write a dawn
well that's the valerian ranked
experience ew ew that's pylon
from genji imfact
[Music]
well colton's incredible right coolton
naturally
we write a
dawn
and i have the water
my mom said she could drive us